Marvin Zuckerman professor emeritus from
the University of Delaware
sensory deprivation we put people in
dark soundproof rooms or water tanks and
people are becoming aware that we needed
sensation stimulation variation
stimulation almost as much as we need
food and water and so forth the basic
need and deprivation of this kind of
stimulation led to some very
uncomfortable states so we we asked is
there a sense a personality trait that
some people need more stimulation or
more variety or intensity of stimulation
than others that's when we developed our
first sensation-seeking scale and
subsequently that expanded became the
main focus of my research is the we were
surprised by how many things were
affected by this trait sensation-seeking
and then we got interested in the
biological basis a genetic and
biological basis and here again we had
some very interesting findings pointing
to the fact that this is a very
fundamental trait with biological roots
Kevin from twin studies called
biometrics of behavior genetics actually
and using both these twin studies we
initially found that roughly 60% the
heritability heritability is the
proportion of the variance trait that's
determined by genetics and we discovered
that was 60% which is very high for
personality trait which generally run
between 30 and 50% so 60% is high for a
personality trait
well it's higher for intelligence and
some other traits so more recently this
was established not only using twins
raised together but twins raised apart
showing that it wasn't due to the fact
of sharing a stimulating environment
let's say there is an environmental
aspect of this of the remaining 40% some
of those error of measurement but some
of it is due to environment but it's not
the shared where we call the shared
environment shared in the family it's
due to the non-shared environment which
means your friends peers your unique
life experiences that you have with
other people in your family you don't
share with other people in your family
we can surmise
is that the fortunately since a
particular gene has been found to be
related the sensation-seeking uh
dopamine receptor gene so that means
it's been there a long time well
actually they estimate that it's pretty
not old evolution you know maybe fifty
thousand hundred thousand years old in
our species this particular gene but
there may be other genes that are old or
even but you see this another the point
as you see what we might call sensations
see analogs of sensation-seeking
behavior and other species like a lot of
my work has compared sensation-seeking
expressions exploration novel approach
the novelty in other species with the
same and explored this that the extent
that they have the same biological roots
in humans and other species so in that
sense we look at evolution we have a
modern test of evolution when you can
find something that exists in humans in
earlier species particularly primates so
now let's say but also even in rats when
you can find this and it's linked to the
same biological indicators in both
species in both humans and other animals
that indicates it has age evolutionary
history rather it's more than merely
analogy oh this looks like what we do
but it's more than that it's that the
fact that it looks like
sensation-seeking
and has the same biological roots
I would say the the age differences are
somewhat larger if you're looking at the
extremes you know I would say it like it
was like at the both 6065 a male would
have half the sensation-seeking score
that he had when he was in his late
teens early 20s so that's pretty much of
a decline the male/female differences
are constant across age but perhaps not
as large as when we talk about sex
differences you know in traits we're
always talking about a lot of overlap
talking about population differences so
people always say I know someone who's
you know the female but is very high
sensation so yeah of course
you know there's variation within both
genders it's just the overall population
difference is different
well we find that both its genetic in
both of males are almost always higher
on the general trait and particularly on
those scales subscales that they have to
deal with impulsivity like we call them
disinhibition for instance one skill and
another thrilling adventure seeking
these are things men are particularly
high on these are things also the peak
and adolescence and decline with age so
that's an interesting thing because
sensation-seeking also Peaks Nautilus
it's higher in men than women Peaks in
that'll essence like late late
adolescence and declines with age
well in the past sensation-seeking was
found in just the struggle for survival
hunting I've imagined the successful
hunters were men who enjoyed it even at
the risk of hunting large mammals or
mammoths and things like that war has
always been fighting among men this it
still is related to sensation-seeking
but in modern Western society or there's
no war most people find their sensation
and other kinds of activities for
instance thrilling adventure seeking
well ordinary sports don't provide much
of that exceptional sports like
skydiving and hang gliding and like
order rafting and things like that
provide the sensation thrilling
adventure seeking for minority people
who engage in them your Mon average man
for instance fine says sensation seeking
the way drives us a car you know and we
find the high sensation seekers hood or
more risky drivers they drive at higher
speeds young males have more accidents
they they tailgate they they use their
cars as a vehicle for thrilling
adventure seeking an aggression
sensation seeking isn't all thrill and
adventurer seeking sensations seeking
has outlets through through there's
other aspects through through sex for
instance which is part of them again the
reason for its survival it was involved
in seeking a mates and some in the some
men and women need a lot of variety in
their sexual outlets and behavior and
others don't need that much variety and
therefore are more monogamous and
so that's in one area drugs drinking
drugs partying these are all outlets for
sensation seekers okay involving
different kinds of risk but involving
risk nevertheless
well there is a four types of
risk-taking which form the core of you
might say of you know smoking drinking
drugs and sex okay
now you can see three of those are
substance abuses and they act through
the central nervous system they act on
centers in the central nervous system
that give intrinsic pleasure okay
particularly stimulant drugs like
cocaine you know they they provide
pleasure
they provide the kick that activities
provide like sex provide for the for the
sensation seeker and they're all
correlated because they're all aspects
of intensity seeking sensation okay and
then novelty - there's a difference
reliance and drug users between those
who are high sensation seekers and those
are low I found this out when I was
treating drug abusers the low sensations
world the average and low sensation teen
drug abuser tries one drug which he
enjoys particularly and sticks to it the
loves try many different drugs so
normally they get into drugs like LSD
that effect their minds as well as their
you know they're provided unusual
sensations as well as arousal the lows
stay away from those drugs
I remember once sitting around on a
discussion with in this drug abusing
community and they were relating their
drug experiences and one of them was a
high sensation seeking LSD user and he
was talking about that he and another
one was shaking his head they asked him
why are you you know what do you think
of this man that's crazy if this is a
heroin egusi understand that state why
wouldn't anyone fool with that that's
dangerous to with your mind you
know he just couldn't understand that he
just used heroin which you know which
eventually initially provides some highs
but eventually is used because it's
quits because of the lows it's just you
know they because you need it to stay
feeling normal okay
you find for instance that high
sensation seekers among the not many men
who love war and combat but there are a
few there are some who really find that
exciting and will revolve here simply
because they're bored with military life
outside of combat and they're in various
substances which are interesting and
that they stimulate the same centers
that that are stimulated by intense and
novel stimuli external stimulation drugs
do that more directly particularly drugs
like cocaine
there is
particularly for one type of sensation
see we call the experience seeking
seeking sensation through the mind in
the senses one type of experience
seeking and sensations to high sensation
seekers are more prone to engage in
divergent thinking these are they don't
think they don't think in the
conventional ways they think tend to
think along unconventional lines so they
and this is a part of creativity
creativity is the ability to think and
do things you know the way that haven't
been done before
part of novelty seeking you might say so
in a sense they tend to be more creative
if they have ability to be creative and
we think of creativity we think of
abilities many of the people who on the
streets or drug yard dealers are very
creative they're creative criminally
they think of new ways of doing the
things you know but we don't call that
creativity even though it is creativity
so it depends oh and what if you have
the ability to pursue your divergent
thinking along lines that have a result
in the production of something whether
it's in business or art or science you
know you have the ability plus the
sensation seeking that makes you more
creative and what you're doing
actually there is no relationship
between sensation-seeking and
neuroticism our anxiety you might this
thing that's funny because they seem to
be lack fear but the kind of fear they
lack is fear of physical harm
neuroticism anxiety is based on
different kind of fear or mostly social
fear and they they don't differ on that
they're independent that's an
independent trait neuroticism so you
find as many hot high sensation seekers
are high as our low and most of our
Djinn neuroticism
it's that physical fear that they differ
them that high sensation seekers tend to
first of all see things as less risky
than loaves if you ask well see if it's
something they've never tried before if
you say how risky is this the highs are
going to say it's riskier and then when
they do it they demonstrate less fear
arousal because fear arousal make
something unpleasant those who are not
that high in sensation seeking they may
get the try it under peer pressure or
something and then they find that
they're tremendous even though no harm
comes to them they find it's a pleasant
unpleasant experience because of the
fear that it arouses so they'll never do
it again they say okay I've done that
although I'm not going to do it again
whereas the the highs value that kind of
whatever fear they felt just gave a
little kick to the experience that made
him even more pleasurable oddly enough
you know because it was fearful they
overcame the fear and they experienced
pleasure
well there's a thing happens with
sensation-seeking habituation
habituation is a basic law of learning
the lowest organisms when you expose
them to something repeatedly over and
over they respond less to it there are
less aroused by it even though initially
it was arousing when they and they get
used to it
and nothing happened this is nothing
particular happens they had listened as
now in violence or insects this this
occurs to habituation you know so what
was initially very rousing let's say
insects you know the honeymoon with time
becomes still pleasurable but less
arousing in the high that's why the high
sensation seekers have to look for new
sources of arousal now this occurs in
films too you start out with simple
horror films you know and and the high
sensation seeker so yeah that's fine but
he gets bored by it and so the the the
when they're allowed to buy legally and
then recently the societies loosen both
laws about depiction of violence and sex
and in the in the media so the they push
it they keep pushing it to the extreme
because they find that a journey people
as high sensation seekers become
habituated they become bored with it and
they need something more they go to
something that's more exciting
same thing in thrill seeking for
instance skydivers they stay find that
very initially very exciting and that's
why they like it the high sensation then
they become used to it so they have to
do new things like they do the stunting
and things like this group things and
then that becomes boring and someone go
on even more dangerous forms like BASE
jumping you know what BASE jumping is
BASE jumping is you jump not from an
airplane but from a cliff or a building
even or when something where you have
very little time to open your parachute
timing is very important and a lot of a
lot more people die at that sort of
parachuting
okay and yet why do they do it you know
because it's really more exciting that's
because the fact that they have less
time it's not that they they do it you
know they be clever think I'm a bitch
rated too less the less arousing formed
the for them now less arousing forms so
that's that's why everything tends to
escalate in the sensation-seeking field
from from minor expert from lesser
expressions to more dangerous sometimes
more dangerous expressions
well what was happening what
psychologically they're just becoming
bored and restless they were high
sensation seekers they're low sensation
seekers they were they weren't too they
were fairly comfortable unless they were
had high anxiety trait they were we
measured actually how much they would
move around we could actually measure
their restlessness at the beginning
first three hours there was no
difference but as time went on the high
scream more and more restless twitching
turning you know on the bed they began
to sing to themselves even though they
knew they weren't supposed to speak or
to stimulate themselves they become the
stimulate themselves so that was the
expression if you go a long period
what's happening in the brain is over
longer periods of time even over shorter
periods is that the the brain waves is
slowing down the basic arousal patterns
in the brain the the alpha waves are
getting slower okay and that the most
people is unpleasant I mean you know the
group below your optimal level of
arousal because for any prolonged period
of time becomes unpleasant and if you
give them any kind of stimulation in
sensory deprivation even looking at the
meaningless blotches of color they will
have at least press a bar to do that
know they're being deprived of something
variety and variety of stimulation and
when you deprive people of that that is
very immersive to them okay it's one of
the ways of torture you actually of
putting people it's not just the social
and sensory deprivation when you put
someone you know it's the sensory
deprivation you put people in the
environment they may not be in the
sensory deprivation but if nothing is
varying in their sensory environment it
is becoming increasingly aversive
no it's not humane and it's not and over
solitary confinement that's gold and you
know in prison this one they want to
punish them and they put them in
solitary confinement which is usually a
sensory deprivation as well because
they're even if there's light in the
cell there's no variation okay nothing
is changing no one to talk to you know
part of social isolation is the lack of
social stimulation okay so this this is
over times is very torturous you might
say it's a it's a mental torture of a
sort that's that is very could be very
effective the torture is often usually
isolate their prisoners before they
begin interrogating them because then
they respond but the tendency to respond
to any stimulation even interrogation
there's more there's more run by the leg
by the sensory deprivation
well as I say it came out of a natural
course out of my research and sensory
deprivation which is the opposite
sensation-seeking
but I must admit perhaps I was at the
time of my life you know I looked at
people and friends who are higher since
high sensation seekers and I looked at
that once I can now use them as well
that kind of a prototype when I was
designing this straight but oh well what
would they what are the things they do
what do they like you know it's kind of
prototype for writing items for my scale
no it didn't of course it went on you
know we have other ways then once we had
these items we have to have the idea it
was a new idea for a trait it was a new
which no one was really measuring at
that time okay so to get my idea I
looked around me at you know and what
people were doing and I said and I and
my first form of this test we dependent
on I'd like to do we say would you like
to do this like would you like to do
parachutes skydiving you know because we
assume most people aren't doing it but
the mirror liking that the wanting to
think thought they would like to do it
is something that characterizes a higher
sensation see here okay whereas a lower
sensation no that's crazy why would I
want to do that you know that's
dangerous so in what people might like
to do well as our first items for our
thrill intervention seeking subscale
okay then we ask what what about B well
we know one of the other aspects but uh
you know when we looked at sex drugs and
we asked questions about would you like
to do this would you like to do that or
in the case of sex what do you like to
do you know or what are your attitudes
store that they permissive attitude some
of the sort of things that we looked at
so that's how I got the initial items
now we have different kinds of items now
the don't include content just the need
for excitement
well I would say to be a publishing
professor teaching you can't be too high
because if you're too high you know you
know you're out of it y'all doing other
things not you're not doing research and
writing so but I was I would say I was
higher than the average than the average
professor okay now recently that became
a moot point when they discovered this
gene the doping for receptor gene now I
was in England by this time I was
getting on an age
mine was my last sabbatical but I had
the chance I was in the genetics lab
there and I had the chance to have my
own DNA an examined for the presence of
this particular gene the form of the
gene so I did and I found I had the long
form of the gene which is the type
associated with sensation-seeking
but as I explained to my colleagues
there my sensation-seeking at that by
the time years 60 minus inflation
seeking was confined to writing the top
of the double-decker bus in London you
know because eight you know you may have
a gene for something but the it's
expression is affected by other
biological factors related to age
normally like the rise of Mao with age
which reduces sensation-seeking
you